hey guys Pete peppers here today we're
gonna talk about the coolest new feature
and farm hero a super saga the wind
while the new windy levels are really
cool they're also quite tricky to figure
out so I hope this video will help you
get moving in the right direction we're
also going to be talking about levels
with fidget the squirrel and on those
levels how to move the squirrel on the
nut together so that you can complete
your goals we have a lot of stuff to go
over so let's get started right away
let's talk about how this wind actually
works and the very first wind level it
gives us a little pop-up that explains
that there's wind on this level and we
see the leaves go by and then it gives
us a little indicator to show us that if
we match towards the left and I've added
this arrow here that the wind moves to
the left and that causes all of the
cropsey's to push in the direction of
our match so this is another left-sided
one you move it to the left and
everything moves left this would happen
on any direction this one here when we
look at the carrot if I move this carrot
down the pieces behind it will fill in
in the direction towards the bottom and
the main thing you need to keep an eye
on and think about here is just where do
you want them to go and which direction
do you need to move the piece you're
gonna swipe in order to make that happen
here's one that goes up you can see if I
move the pair up everything moves up and
then I'll just leave a couple more here
where you can watch and sort of guess by
watching the cursor which way you think
it's gonna go
[Music]
so the question I've heard the most on
my farm here a super saga tips Facebook
page is how do I move the squirrel to
the nut the wind on squirrel low-levels
works exactly the same but for some
reason can be a little bit harder to get
used to here we're not just trying to
move you know crops one way or the other
we're trying to bring two objects
together so remember the direction you
swipe the crop C to make the match will
always be the direction the wind will
push so if you want to move the Acorn to
the right you will want to swipe a crop
C to the right in front of the actual
object so in this example we have the
squirrel at the top and we have the the
Acorn down at the bottom in order to
collect the nut we're gonna have to move
these two pieces closer together and you
can see by watching the the cursor how
we're making matches either from the top
to the bottom or the bottom to the top
in order to get them together at this
point we hit a snag we don't have one
that's clear and right in front that
will move them together so we have to
figure out another way to do it in this
particular case I'm gonna use a super
crop C because that actually boosts the
squirrels tail if you watch here he
reaches a little bit further it's sort
of like a Superman so we look at one
more example that's a little bit more
complicated and hopefully that'll get
you ready to learn how to conquer the
windy levels so here we have the
squirrel down at the bottom the acorn up
at the top and they're on opposite sides
of the board so one of the things to
keep in mind when you're doing this is
you could make this match in two
different ways you could move the blue
down or the yellow up obviously we want
to move the blue down so that the Acorn
I'm going down same thing here we want
to move the banana up so that the the
squirrel will come out of the little
notch on the side
so just keep an eye on where we can move
things we can go left or right or up or
up and down and in this example we want
to move the squirrel to the left because
that'll give us a little more room to
work
[Music]
we can move them up this is an example
where you know you might want to just
get rid of all the purple but we can
actually move the acorn rather close so
I'm gonna go ahead and do that instead
now I can just go ahead and match the
water and that'll put them right next to
each other so they're touching and
that's all you have to do so I hope this
video was helpful I hope that you know
you keep in mind that the windy levels
do take a little bit little practice but
if you follow that rule you'll be able
to beat them all sooner or later so just
remember whichever direction you swipe
the very first crop seed to make the
match that's where the winds gonna push
and what you need to move the screw on
the nut together just look for matches
that are in front of one or the other
that moves them closer together please
like the video and subscribe to my
channel thanks a lot